hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of modeling the masters
today we're going to look at how a young
boy from a family of ten in Mississippi
was always looking out for opportunities
and turned a fifteen thousand dollar
investment into a multi-billion dollar
empire
this is a story of Robert Johnson and a
top three lessons that you can learn
from his success Robert Johnson is an
American businessman best known for
being the founder of television network
block entertainment television
eet in 2001 Johnson became the first
African American billionaire and the
first black person to be listed on any
of Forbes as a world's rich list Johnson
was born in Mississippi and was a ninth
of 10 children according to Johnson we
weren't a well firm family but we knew
that if we wanted a bicycle and when
somebody else wasn't going to get
something else if you wanted to go to
college
you knew your parents couldn't pay your
way he had an entrepreneurial Drive and
used his $15,000 in savings to launch B
et in 1980 it started with only two
hours of old movies each Friday in fact
for the first five years speed he would
lose money soon however it began to
expand his programming and cable
operators jumped on board they believed
that many of their subscribers would be
interested in watching block oriented
shows eleven years after its initial
launch B et became the first black owned
company to be listed on a New York Stock
Exchange today B et has spin-off
channels and is the largest black-owned
cable company in history
Johnson bought back all the BT stock
seven years after went public for 1
billion dollars he then sold it to media
giant Viacom two years later for three
billion dollars
by always looking for opportunities and
by starting small Johnson turned a
fifteen thousand dollar investment into
a fortune to help you build on your
opportunities here are three action
items you can learn from Robert Johnson
action item number one always be growing
as entrepreneurs we need to always be
finding new customers and growing our
businesses whether it's launching new
products offering more services
aggressively marketing your existing
solutions need to always be growing
Johnson has been called a serial
entrepreneur thanks to his love of
starting new businesses on-the-fly
throughout his career however if there
has been one thing that he's learned
it's this there are always new customers
to go after according to Johnson if
there's something I can do and I feel it
should be done I just want to do it I
just don't want to leave it undone
because I'll sit back and say why didn't
I do that why didn't I start that
business action item number two be
opportunistic entrepreneurs are the
special individuals who can spot
opportunities and then turn them into
profitable businesses in order to start
a new company or grow your existing one
you should always have an eye out for
new opportunities where Johnson sees a
chance to make money he jumps at it no
if ands or buts about it
while his critics use that fact as one
more chance to knock him down
Johnson attributes his success largely
to his opportunism Johnson is an
entrepreneur plain and simple he wants
to make money and lots of it
according to Johnson whenever I see an
opportunity and a chance to change
something I go at it be et was never a
legacy event for me
BT was something I started as an
investment and I knew someday I would
sell it
action um number three ignore your
critics if you're doing something
different then you're gonna have your
critics people are going to attack you
for your ideas and try to knock you down
it's gonna come from our competitors and
in many cases even come from our friends
and family Johnson had a lot of critics
as he built his business one of his
greatest successes in his own mind he's
been in Africa merican who succeeded at
the highest level since he felt that
nobody expects minorities to be there as
much as others tried to paint his career
in terms of black and white johnson has
refused to let others identify him as
anything other than an entrepreneur and
a good one at that according to Johnson
today if I were to put on jeans and walk
into a jewelry store and I could
probably buy the jewelry store ten times
over but the jeweler is gonna look at me
as a black guy in jeans who probably
can't afford it and maybe who just might
steal something so remember always be
growing be opportunistic and ignore your
critics to finish up this video I wanted
to share one of my favorite true stories
about Robert Johnson and some of his
best quotes after being the first in his
family to go to college
Johnson plan to start a career as a
government worker that all changed from
the national cable and
Telecommunications Association hired
Johnson as a lobbyist for the nascent
cable industry that experience proved to
be a wake-up call for Johnson he began
to think about his own opportunity to
create a cable channel just for
african-americans and would soon go on
to launch be ETA
thank you for joining me for another
edition of modeling the masters if you
enjoyed the video please give it a
thumbs up I'd also love to hear thoughts
and feedback if you want to leave a
comment below the video and stay tuned
to the next episode
you